tell me if there's logic in this if it
makes sense uh uh pull this one up I
don't know if you guys have seen it or
not this story just came out okay so U.S
women's soccer team will pocket at least
six and a half million dollars
uh from the men's team reaching the
World Cup knockout rounds more than they
received for winning two successive
World Cup so did you guys understand the
story so they get 13 million I'll read
the U.S women's National cup so uh right
there the Men's National Team is now
guaranteed a prize of 13 million dollars
after it's 1-0 win they're gonna go into
the final 16 meaning the U.S women's
national team will take a cut of six and
a half million dollars if the men win
their match against Netherlands on
Saturday to reach the quarterfinals
they'll be taking home a minimum of 17
million dollars what do you think about
this concept of whatever men do we have
to pay half of it to women I mean
address fair and equal that's what it is
yeah
uh that kid he's right yeah no it's I
mean it's ridiculous you know I got to
look more I did a whole piece on the U.S
women's national team when they were
complaining about the about getting the
deal that they wanted uh which a lot of
people don't know is they bought they
asked for their original deal they were
the ones to petitioned for it and then
they didn't want to have it afterwards
so we did a whole piece of that during
the pandemic but yeah it seems
absolutely ridiculous you know I think
it's um
yeah it just seems a bit I mean I don't
know get paid what you generate you know
eat what you kill seems like the most
reasonable situation Adam what do you
think about this well I'm gonna uh bring
up one of Andrew Schultz's jokes here
I'm not going to do a copyright thing
this is yours I'm saying that up front
but in your special infamous you address
these types of issues feminism you were
like the part in the crowd where you
were like yeah yeah I think we're on the
same page here guys yeah well you know
like I went to one of these feminist
marches they're screaming Free the
nipple you're like sounds good
all right you know I think we should
have abortion it's like yeah that'd be
good okay right like you were like um
yeah we need to wait for them pay for
our half [ __ ] do it yeah right and he
was like are you guys feminists or [ __ ]
boys right now yeah that whole joke
right there yeah yeah how feminists are
becoming the men that they hated exactly
yeah and it was such a such an amazing
perspective and the way that you kind of
heated up with the audience yeah yeah
that's essentially this right here yeah
this is redistribution of wealth though
right and this is something you're not
actually a fan of iso and right you know
why because okay so we we talked to our
expert Malik and I said who gets paid
who gets paid on the women's side who
makes the most money and we'll look out
of nowhere says well women make more
money and porn and uh modeling yeah you
watch a little too much porn movies I
hope I hope you're in the back watching
paying attention not watching other
Clips on your phone watching if you know
what I mean
he's busy check the check
[Laughter]
so if you say that's a woman female
models they're making a lot more money
than what are we gonna do let's take it
and split it just doesn't make any sense
of women go to go to college man that's
unfair
64 to 36 yeah we gotta stop women from
learning bro according to that we should
stop at least 14 of these women going
out there and learning like or I guess
maybe the population's like 55. but
still it's absurd yeah so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]